[Music]
you know I I want to get all of kind of
like our product placement on the first
page so this is like it's how you have
many many bloomberg logos and then the
rest of talk is very few so you're
welcome so I'm going to talk about a
topic that I have been very very
personally excited about and interested
in for a bunch of years so let me kind
of tell you how I got into it so deep
learning has had a huge enough has had a
huge effect it's you know the first area
as kind of I'm sure all you guys know at
this point is was in images and an image
recognition of course this is you know
one of the most important problems in
image recognition which is is cat
recognition and you know the success of
deep learning techniques on image net in
there you know early 2010's had a huge
effect in how people thought about deep
learning and how people thought about
machine learning and you know there are
a lot of successes in images images are
kind of very interesting as a problem
domain they're very dense they were a
lot of regularity they're also kind of a
surface domain you know the the you know
a picture as a representation of a scene
it's a fairly one-to-one representation
every pixel on the screen Maps very
naturally to a 3d point and so we're
covering the 3d structure and kind of
recovering what's going on in the scene
is fairly straightforward
and it actually has been was a number of
years after after cats that work on text
started to kind of have the same see the
same kind of impact as a day images you
know it is actually and I come from a
text world that was my
and so you know for a number of years
most of the machine that NLP conferences
were somewhat lukewarm about deep
learning they were interested they were
they certainly noticed the impact in in
images but there wasn't as much of an
impact in text they they didn't notice
as much of an impact on on text and so
you know the NLP community was kind of
looking around and and and they saw
small gains in a lot of the men lpe
techniques and there were small gains in
mt there were small gains here and there
but it really didn't change the field it
was like okay here's another technique
which is a little bit better
unlike in images whereas a lot better
and actually in the past year or two
that has really dramatically changed and
things are possible in NLP that weren't
really possible a few years before and
the text generation is a good example so
this is a GPT - snippet you know and
it's kind of remarkable at just how
fluent it is is still nonsensical and
and gibberish though you know hard to
distinguish from some people at this
point and so you know but this kind of
stuff was really not possible a number
of years ago okay but there are a bunch
of other problems so here is a kind of
weird little problem that we've been
looking at which is scatter plots so you
have a plot of some data and there and
each of those points represents a XY
which represents a real data point and
the the problem simply defined is you
have your scatter plot and now extract
all of the data points it's not totally
straightforward because I you have to
there are a lot of things you have to
understand about this image you have to
understand okay well what are the axes
what are the axes represent what are the
tick marks what do they represent and
kind of unlike images and unlike natural
language text there are a lot of
different layers of understanding that
you need to get through in order to
understand this image
here's another problem this is tables so
tables again I love boring things tables
are pretty boring so naturally I love
them and so you know a table is you know
a bunch of rows and columns and there's
stuff in the rows and you know in order
to understand this table there are also
a lot of pieces that you have to unpack
you know what are the order the units in
each of these in each of the columns you
know in this case this is a fairly
simple table but you might imagine that
they're you know rows which are multi
rows or columns which are multi columns
and so that you know the even there's a
little bit of a hierarchical structure
that encodes what the semantics of the
table are apart from you know the actual
physical numbers and then one of the
interesting things as you can see is
actually a little program a dopey little
program maybe but it is a little program
which defines this table this is la tech
la tech of course is Turing complete and
so this is is a Turing a sample from
turn complete program but again it's a
fairly simple program and actually the
state of the art on tables is is
actually not that great so we did some
experiments we've published a bunch of
work that a great intern Yun Tian Deng
did some early work on equation
understanding you have a picture of an
equation you want to recover the
actually the formula the law tech
formula and then we applied this model
to tables and the way we collected these
tables was we looked at archive and we
scraped all the documents on archive and
we extracted all the table segments so
these are kind of fair natural tables
and now you have a training and a test
set you can regenerate all these tables
and we looked at performance at
recovering the lot X structure of these
tables and the performance is actually
really not that great it's about 40% of
youn tans model a complete text recovery
we also made this this
said downloadable so there's about
400,000 of these
scrape blot tech tables that can get to
through you tans website or as github I
guess so there are few things so one is
you know the performance on recovery
from these images of this table is
actually pretty bad and especially bad
you know you you would think that a cat
recognition is a harder problem than
table recognition tables again pretty
boring cats are kind of fun but actually
it's a fairly hard problem and and once
you start to think about it in that way
it starts to expose that you know a lot
of the problems that have you know been
pushed by machine learning and by deep
learning are on fairly surface I don't
wanna say easy problems are very hard
but they're kind of surface problems now
again you know it might be possible that
tables are so boring we haven't as a
community expended as much energy into
understanding tables as we have to
understanding images it's possible and
it also might be possible that there's
some underlying phenomenon okay but
tables are a instance of a program a
very very simple simple program but
actually there are many more complicated
programs so this is a snippet of code
from from one of you know my I personal
you know or is it you know people that
you aspire one of my personal idols
kerning ham and pike this is a regular
expression is a complete regular
expression parser it's it's fairly
simple it has like makes a few number
the language that accepts is small but
you can see this is you know again 40 or
so lines of code maybe 20 lines of code
it's kind of remarkable and the amount
of phenomenon that it describes is vast
the the thing that is actually computing
whether you know a regular expression
has whether a string has matched a
regular expression is if an arbitrary
regular expression is a fairly deep kind
of it
to process you know so you know one of
the so for the rest of talk I'm going to
do two kinds of things one is I want to
tell you a little bit about various
things people in the literature have
done to think about programs modeling
programs learning programs and then I'm
going to tell you about this other
problem that I have become very obsessed
with to the point that I think my kids
are gonna start teasing me about it
which is software fuzzing and I spent a
little bit of time on that I'm gonna
tell you why I've been obsessed by it
and some of the things that that we've
discovered through it so you know one of
the first things you might think about
when you're thinking about programming
is or learning programs is you know what
can can can deep learning or machine
learning synthesize programs denovo you
know we can synthesize language is
pretty awesome
can we synthesize programs so let me
tell you about the most successful
synthetic programs out there so so this
is it you may have used it this is the
excel flash fill plug in you you have
some columns and you fill in kind of
your initial data and then you have
another column where you fill in the
piece that you want to extract from it
and then the model learns this is a
programming by example kind of paradigm
and and generates a program that then
extracts now what does it actually learn
it's not it's learning a very small
subclass of programs which are regular
expressions regular expressions are
little finite state machines and so it
generalizes and you know one of the nice
things about this kind of paradigm is
that you know as you're going through
you can update and tweak and kind of add
examples if you if you notice that it's
you know going in a weird direction and
this this work which is now deployed and
used kind of throughout the world was a
huge huge achievement and a huge
software achievement and this is you
know
fairly state of the art learning regular
expressions and this is maybe 2012-2013
around there okay so so this is like
small kind of a language small kind of a
program let's see what there's you know
neural you know architectures can do so
this is a beautiful piece of work that
came out of deep Google brain I think
actually in 2014 it was a neural Turing
machine and so here they took ALS TM and
the lsdm in addition to outputting you
know particularly output tokens could
also modify some memory and so they
could store stuff and they could
retrieve stuff from memory and then they
and so they tried to see what kinds of
programs this architecture could learn
and the the pinnacle achievement which
was actually like really I say
preservative Lee but it really was a
huge achievement was they they wrote
essentially this program which is you
take in a a sequence of twenty
characters and then you take them all in
and then you output that sequence of
twenty characters that was a program so
this is 2014 you know are the world's
most brilliant scientists that were
working on this problem that was the
level of program synthesis that they
were able to achieve again not
productively
it really wasn't achievement but it's
just a very hard problem so a few years
past and then another group this was
deep mind I think Fernando de Freitas
also brilliant worked on an architecture
called a neural program interpreter now
in the neural Turing machine and they
also programmed it by examples here they
programmed it a little bit differently
they they had a program they observe the
program traces that the execution traces
for the program and then they use that
for training and their goal was they
wanted to come up with an embedding that
represented a program and then they
executed that embedding by putting it
through their neural interpreter and
this is the program that the machine
learned this is bubble sort
and they did it over many many examples
and again this was a huge achievement
and it was kind of amazing that it
learned bubble sort at all but there was
a big asterisk they trained it up to
sequences of length 20 and it worked on
sequences of length up to length 60 and
then it was kind of unstable after that
so they wrote the you know the program
learned a bubble sort that was buggy and
only kind of worked on length 60
examples this is again a monumental
scientific achievement but in terms of
concrete practical use it really really
is not there it leaves a lot to be
desired
and again no fault on the researchers
wonderful piece of work but I think this
demonstrates you know the gap of just
how difficult the program synthesis
problem is and so one thing that kind of
if one of the reactions of the field was
to say oh okay wow that was harder than
we thought let's try something easier
and so recently there have been a bunch
of groups that have looked at learning
and learning programs in much simpler
context and these feel actually much
more like the table problems so this is
a this is learning a particular kind of
program this is a 3d shape program so
you you have this 3d image and you want
to come up with a program that generates
that shape and so for this a beautiful
table and I guess that's an end table or
side table you infer this program and
then you can execute this program and a
lot of it this was this was that I
cleared this year this is fresh off the
press and the way that they do it
technically is they simultaneously build
two things they build a something that
[Music]
understands the image and and brings it
down to a
a riddim representation or it sorry a
embedding embedding representation and
then they learn a renderer that takes
that representation and creates the 3d
image and because they have the whole
loop process and they're able to back
prop through the process and learn both
those pieces super super interesting and
very effective in these kinds of context
learning you know this kind of robust
representation for this 3d image is
complicated there are a lot of nice
properties this representation has it's
simple you can manipulate it you can
start to reason with it and the fact
that they could learn it is is really
nice now the you know this as a
technique learning a kind of a inference
engine which gets a program and in a
rendering engine however is a little bit
specific to images nice thing about
these images is that they're
compositional you know the the top of
the table is going to look the same no
matter what the other commands are and
so you can very neatly break this
program up into little pieces this isn't
true for a lot of the other programs
that we deal with you know things aren't
really atomic there's some state which
is transferred and there's not this so
so the kinds of things I do here not
clear they're going to transfer but this
idea has kind of been applied in another
domain this idea of you know
simultaneously learning both in
inference engine and a rendering engine
to the problem of you know learning with
a black box function so you might
imagine you have some deep net and you
want to call out to some other black box
function how do you integrate learning
how to call out to that function and how
to process your data to call that out so
you might imagine you have a bubble sort
you know how do you integrate bubble
sort without learning it de novo into
your deep learning model and this is a
way of doing it and really the way that
they do it is very much the same as this
3d shape program which is you
probabilistic lis model your black box
and now that and you write you know a
deep net equivalent of this back box
that you train I know you can back prop
through this black box and then at
inference time you swap out the real
thing
so you say okay well this is what I how
I imagined bubble sort might work and
now at inference time I'm just gonna
plug in actually the real bubble sort
which is more robust but at least the
rest of my system has been tuned so that
you know it knows how to communicate to
this subsidiary system okay but you can
see like the the gap between the
aspirations in 2014 which are we're
gonna learn programs directly from
examples using a neural Turing machine
have kind of been much reduced in 2019
simply because it's hard now of course
you know we've been communicating with
computers about code for a long time and
the code that we write I mean is
connected though somewhat only
tangentially to what the computer is
actually executing you know there's this
entire process where we take your
high-level language you know and and we
can quibble about whether C is a
high-level language but you take a
high-level language and you encode it in
assembly code and this is actually I
cheated here this is actually not
assembly code this is the LLVM internal
representation so it's even before
assembly code but you convert it into
something which is fairly low-level that
is then executed by the computer and of
course you know this process itself is
not you know there aren't a whole lot of
people that are still writing assembly
these days everything there that people
are doing on computers is mediated by a
compiler so kind of a natural next
question is you know if we can't get
computers to kind of synthesize programs
from whole cloth you know how can we get
computers to help in this process of
compiling code so let me tell you about
a paper from a few years ago which
really kind of blew my mind though is
you know maybe obvious that you should
try it it's in what's called super
optimization so in the process of
compilation there are many ways to
render your high-level language into
low-level code and there are a lot of
questions on how you want to do
ordering of your statements how you you
know how you want to do register
management what you want to swap out to
memory and what do you want to keep in
memory there are a lot of very very low
level questions and usually the way that
people have approached them from the
compiler community is to use heuristics
you know let's let me think about what's
a good heuristic for this kind of model
or let me model this little piece and
solve it exactly this takes this work
takes a very different approach what it
does is for loop free code so like if
you're ever if you're familiar where the
hacker is to like code they have little
snippets of code which computes
something and they have no loops they
take this loop free code and they
rewrite it they reorder it and what this
this paper does is it says okay let me
look at the space of possible rewritings
let me sample from that space now I'm
going to check I'm gonna run the program
I'm gonna see how long that that
rewriting took and then you know
depending on you know the constraints my
model they they use a Monte Carlo model
to do the sampling I'm going to decide
whether to keep that rewrite or throw it
out and then I'm also going to improve
my sampling distribution is or I'm going
to observe whether that rewrite decrease
the latency or didn't decrease the
latency and I'm gonna somehow think
about my sampling method in order to
improve it so it's kind of wild because
at least for me it kind of opened the
door to thinking about okay compilation
as a learning process or a stochastic
process that you might imagine
optimizing whereas you know this this
loop free this super optimization you
know they showed you know using their
experiments that they actually got
significant gains over their base
compilers in these cases now whether or
not that you know figuring out how to
scale that up to arbitrary code which of
course has loops it's a big challenge
but you know there is this this kind of
result is the door that kind of opens to
thinking about really a massive change
in the way that we design our compute
tools and let me give you kind of one
other weird compilation example so this
is actually a D compilation so you know
I often you know we all live in
high-level or at least I mostly live in
high-level languages but for various
applications particular security
applications you want to live in a
low-level language you might only have
the binary as given to you by you know
some company that you're contracting
with how do you start to understand that
binary and verify security properties
and and one way you might think about
doing that is going from this low level
assembly code into a high level code
that can then analyze so over the and
this is a not this is a non-trivial
problem they're there to kind of they're
there at least two problems that
immediately jump out there I imagine
there are many many other problems one
is that during the compilation process
if it turned out off debugging you don't
have any variable assignments any
variable names and so the code is a
little bit hard to read you also don't
have any loops excuse me you don't have
any nicely structured loops you have go
twos which kind of tell you to jump
someplace in the program and you have
like these branches but it looks like
spaghetti code that's why you write one
of the reasons you write in a high level
language of course all of the nicely you
know nice object structures and punchy
tables are also kind of garbled so you
know there's a lot of structure which is
lost from going to from a high level
language to assembly language and there
are a lot of challenges in reversing
this process and there has been some
work which has kind of been very
interesting on reversing this one of the
nice things from machine learning
perspective is you know with you know in
this setting it's very easy to generate
a huge amount of training data because
you just run your compiler and so there
have been a lot of techniques that have
started to use
Nura mission translation or you know
neuro machine translation oh by ok neuro
machine translation with you know some
additional back pieces to recover but
there's not been a huge amount of impact
so and likewise for bug fixing the
things that have been deployed in
industry around bug fixing are very very
preliminary so let me tell you about an
area where machine learning is actually
poised to have a huge impact on
programming and that's in software
fuzzing so software fuzzing is in the
testing phase and so the the definition
of the fuzzing problem is very
straightforward you have an arbitrary
binary and you want to find security
flaws in that binary and the proxy to
this is that instead of finding flaws
you say you say ok well let me just try
to explore all possible program behavior
by coming up with inputs which explore
as much of it as possible they're a
bunch of different techniques so since
we're kind of short on time let me just
talk about gray box fuzz testing so the
the idea of gray box fuzz testing is you
get a binary you're allowed to
instrument it very lightly and then you
go through this loop which is you have
an input you run it against the binary
you observe where the you observe the
program execution and now you choose a
new input string and now you and you
repeat so it's appealing for a lot of
reasons one reason is that it it feels a
little bit maybe like reinforcement
learning problem and a little bit like a
learning problem and the other reason is
that it's been phenomenally successful
even without you know in a very very
simple context so if you use heuristics
and random distributions for uniform
random distributions for mutation
insight and child selection
AFL has has really been huge and I'll
skip over this but just when I flash
this up quickly so AFL has been widely
deployed and discovered bugs on software
I'm sure that you've used and these are
in you know little bugs these are
security violations
you know buffer overrides memory you
know wrong memory access and so there
this tool software fuzzing even without
any you know with you know almost the
the minimal amount of stochastic
stochasticity has had a huge impact on
software on deployed software and so I
want to tell you two things that we've
done and I'll go quickly to be mindful
of time to think about taking this
stochastic process and taking this this
problem and making it more like a
machine learning problem so the first is
ok well if this is a stochastic process
you might imagine that you know what
happens let me go through the algorithm
at each stage you pick a seed that
you've tried before that's been
productive you pick a mutation operator
you apply that mutation operator to your
input seed and you might do that and you
do that a number of times and now you
have a new input and now you run that
input so you know the mutation operators
are things like ok you want to flip a
bit or change a byte to a special byte
or insert some span of code and there
are about in AFL they're around 16 of
those it depends how you count but you
can imagine they're around 16 and
they're selected uniformly at random and
so one question is well why would you
assume that uniform at random is
actually the right distribution is there
something special about that
distribution or is it really true that
all the mutation operators are equally
as good and so we used something called
Thompson sampling which is also known as
posterior sampling to to think about how
to select these mutation operators again
I'll kind of skip through
but in our setting what we use is we
said okay each mutation operator is in
action and the reward signal that I'm
going to train on is did this mutated
seed actually discover new behavior did
it go down a new input path and so what
we found is that changing just the the
distribution over mutation operators
significantly increased the amount of
coverage code coverage for these input
seeds and so there really was nothing
special about the uniform distribution
it was just kind of like an arbitrary
distribution we could have done a lot
better let me tell you about one more
experiment we did in fuzzing so we said
okay well in the first kind of viewpoint
we looked at fuzzing as a process let's
think about it instead and modeling the
outputs so once you've kind of gone
through your process however you did you
have a string is there a way to evaluate
whether that string is going to be a
useful string or not and so what we did
is we said okay this is our process
we're going to take this input string
and we're going to build a predictive
model given this string can I predict
what output path what execution trace it
goes through how does it traverse a
particular program and I'm going to
build a model I think we built a
logistic regression model but you can
imagine subsequently we've built you
know deep models and so we said okay
well let's we're going to treat this as
a modeling problem and we're think about
this a little bit like an active
learning problem you have some candidate
inputs which is the best candidate input
to try that's going to improve your
model the most and a fairly conventional
technique for active learning is is
entropy yeah you know maximum entropy
selection and so so the way we
implemented that was you know in this
kind of way you have AFL for the our
purposes we modify the the selection
criteria you generate a lot of different
inputs using your stochastic process and
then you
look at your predictive model and you
rank all of those inputs and then you
choose the inputs which the model is
unsure about where they're gonna go and
you select those inputs to run excuse me
and then you know our experimental setup
we're an AFL for a certain amount of
time we generated some seeds we built a
model and then at that point we we built
we use this model to do entropy ranking
and so again here the performance of
this entropy model gave significant
gains over kind of random AFL model okay
so so let me close up with just a few
observations so you know I've gone
through talking about program synthesis
the compilation process and finally
testing and so you know I I think I'll
make the argument again you know in the
case of program synthesis a very
interesting problem incredibly hard
problem the state of the art is very far
from addressing and having any near-term
industrial impact it's a great problem
for basic research in compilation work
closer there are a lot of places where
you know on certain arbitrary subsets
compilation process can be vastly
improved and D compilation is also kind
of Amina Bowl
however in in software testing this is
an area where the tools as deployed are
making a significant impact and machine
learning has a capacity to really
improve these testing tools as they are
so and I and I feel like we have really
just scratched the surface the two
things that there's a lot of work in
past years on fuzzing there's actually a
fuzzing paper or paper at ngerous but
the the the amount of information that
you can get from a program and from runs
on the program is really quite a lot and
so I think that there's a lot of room
for doing more deep program
analysis and putting that into into the
fuzzing process and then I'll kind of
like take one step back and you know
these are in general kind of my feelings
or observations out of this work is that
one is that you know in the context of
software infrastructure reinforcement
learning is a very interesting technique
Thompson sampling is kind of like a
little baby of a reinforcement learning
strategy it's really a contextual bandit
strategy or bandit strategy it's not a
true reinforcement learning strategy but
in general you know once you have a
computational system that you can
simulate and execute many many times its
amenable to reinforcement learning
techniques in a way that image
processing and natural language really
aren't a robotic certainly is but image
and natural language are in software
infrastructure is great area for
reinforcement learning and the second is
you know there is a lot of interesting
work around black box learning you know
in the case of these 3d programs there's
applications there but in general
thinking about how we model arbitrary
code not for the purpose of synthesis
exactly but for other purposes testing
compilation debugging there are a lot of
very interesting pieces there and then
I'll take one more step back which is
just to say that machine learning on
programs as objects as opposed to on
images or in text is is truly in its
infancy we're already in the case of
fuzzing seeing some concrete industry
impacts to this work and my guess is
that this is an area where there's gonna
be a lot more impact over the next 5-10
years and that is it thank you very much
so thanks for tacos really good when are
we talking about having compilers
replace heuristic based approaches to
sort of try and improve like assembly
code and using like random swap to
something I think you just mentioned
that the old the old approach was to
have compiler writers use heuristics do
you know if anyone ever taking a look at
the output of like the actions that
those improvements have take have taken
like all the swaps and random mutations
and generated new heuristics for
improving compilers so so you know I
ain't have time to go into but there is
actually a lot of a lot of very
interesting work out of the software
engineering community on thinking about
integrating machine learning into the
heart of the compiler in various
different kinds of ways you know I and
you know this super optimization is kind
of like an extreme case but but there
are many many different compiler
decisions and if you search you'll find
you know there are some very nice
reviews that review compiler piler
optimization
[Music]